- A lot of people watching
right now are like,
"But social's not working for me."
And I'm like, "The
creative is the variable."
(upbeat music)
You got your perspective.
I just want to be happy,
don't you want to be happy?
- All right, first up,
we're kicking off the show
with Shark, Barbara Corcoran.
Her credits include straight
Ds in high school and college.
She had 20 jobs by the time she turned 23.
And then she borrowed $1,000,
quit her job as a waitress,
and started a tiny real estate
company in New York City
that is now a $5,000,000,000
real estate business.
Welcome Barbara!
- Hey, my pleasure to be here.
I love Gary, I'll do anything for him.
- Barbara, it's great to see you.
It's always great to see you.
Happy holidays and pending new year.
We don't have a lot of time,
so I'm gonna get right into it
cause I know a lot of people were excited
that you were gonna be on the show,
so thanks for kicking us off.
In your opinion, which
consumer behavior shift
will be key to driving growth in 2021?
- Am I allowed to pick more than one?
- Yes.
- Cause I think there's
probably four or five out there, okay.
- Yes you are.
- Number one, the customer's in charge.
I think if we didn't
understand that before,
we certainly understand it now.
The behavior that we
collaborate with the customer
is over with, they're
in charge, end of story.
So I think the key here as an entrepreneur
is you have to stay very
close to your customer.
Listen hard and see what they need.
And I think the first thing
they need is they want safety.
And that ain't gonna go away either.
And when I say safety, I think
you have to put safety first.
Customers demand it,
and you don't have to worry
about how to pay for it.
Because you can't afford to
worry about how to pay for it,
you just have to do it.
I think social media is the
fastest and cheapest way
to communicate what the safety measures
your particular business has done.
And I think the social
distancing protocols
that we've all recently encountered
are here to stay as well.
Things like the dots on the floor,
I don't expect them to go
away next year at this time.
Mounted thermometers at restaurant doors.
Discretionary masks for travel.
I think it's all, we're gonna
just see a softer version
of the same old and it
ain't gonna go away.
But safety is what people care about now
and they will continue-
- How, how,
how long do you, let
me jump in on that one.
- Yeah.
- You know, okay, so we see a softening,
let's say a year from today.
Do you think, do you see a time
where we go back to 2019 levels?
Or do you think this is
now stuck in our culture
for quite a long time?
- It's part of our culture,
it's not gonna go away.
Would you travel in an airplane,
whether your traveling
business class or coach,
and not wear a mask?
I wouldn't, never again.
I mean, I kind of wanted to do that
when people were coughing next to me
but I thought it was socially rude.
Nope, I'm going on the airplane
with a mask forevermore.
I don't want to catch what's going around.
You know, nothing's gonna go away totally.
We'll have a residual that will become
part of our culture, definitely.
- Understood, keep going.
- Okay, online shopping is king.
I mean, I almost feel
embarrassed to say that.
Everybody knows that, okay.
- Yeah.
- But I think part and parcel of that
is you need to go to
where the customer is.
I have one business named
Cousins Maine Lobster,
a large franchise of lobster trucks.
- Yes, I like those guys.
- Yeah, those guys, I think
you interviewed Sabin-
- Yeah.
- Yeah, a smart entrepreneur.
- Smart.
- But the moment Covid
hit, that guy had pivot,
I hate the word pivot
but I'll have to use it
because I don't know what to substitute.
Oh, he turned his business around,
there's a new substitute I can use.
With contactless pickup,
communicating where his
trucks are gonna be,
and he moved his trucks
out of the normal places
that were crowded and he utilized
every single large
shopping mall parking lot.
Gave people numbers, they waited in line,
picked up, they went home
with their dinner out,
and his increase in sales
went through the roof
within a month and a half.
Pretty sharp, but he
understood that he needed to go
to where the customer
was comfortable being.
I also have a business that's
my most successful business
named Comfy, and what it
is is a wearable sweatshirt
and what they did is they
had $150,000,000 in sales
in big box stores that
were sent back to them
when Covid hit because the big box stores
they were merchandising to had closed.
What were they gonna do?
They increased their sales
online, turned up a website
that they hadn't taken
seriously as before,
and they turned a $150,000,000 in sales
into $250,000,000 in sales.
They went to where the
customer wanted to be,
that's exactly what they did.
And then also, again obvious
so I hesitate to say it,
social media is the name of the game.
I mean, I don't invest in a
single business this season
on Shark Tank unless I
felt that the entrepreneur
was almost a borderline
genius on social media
because I know were gonna have to rely
on the social media platforms forevermore
because we have spoiled
our customers with this
and they want it.
In social media, I think key
traits or key entrepreneurs,
or pardon me, key employees
that all of us need
as entrepreneurs are now the producers,
the storytellers, the videographers,
it's really become the new norm.
They used to be extra people.
It was nice, a luxury feature if you want.
But with social media
being the name of the game
it's not the case anymore.
- Barbra, real quick on that.
I'm sorry to interrupt.
When you were building
your real estate empire,
so much of it to do with branding,
was direct mail a very
strong pillar for you
in the prime of your growth?
- Yes it was but,
everyone used direct mail,
but the way I was able to become
extremely successful with it
is that I used postcards
because I watched people
at home, including myself,
and I didn't open junk mail.
- Right.
- But a postcard I was forced to read.
That's what we used, yes.
- So you paid, you paid higher
to be your individual postcard
versus maybe in a value
pack and you feel like
even though you were paying more
to get into a mailbox, you
were getting seen more often
and that gave you a leg up?
- It gave me a leg up but honestly
I never considered value packs
cause I'm too selfish, I want
my own stage wherever I am
and I got in on a postcard.
What was more effective
than the postcard campaigns
I constantly ran, was buying billboards
10 cents on the dollar.
- Remnant inventory, right?
- Remnant inventory.
- I did the same thing
for one of my brands.
- In New York and that put my
brand frontline and center,
billboards were the king.
And then also what a lot
of people didn't know then
that I took full advantage of,
was I bought remnant space
in the New York Times
and the Wall Street Journal
previously saved for retailers.
But when I checked into their rules,
retail was not the rule,
it was just ShopRite
and everybody was using them,
and I started putting
full page advertisements
for all my properties
that looked at a billion
when I really had 10 cents on
the dollar on that as well.
- It's funny, I really think
your career and knowing it,
being an east coast guy, you know,
a lot of people think
about me with social media
but I got my chops in direct mail,
print, outdoor, radio-
- Wow.
- Cause I was advertising as
like a kid for my dad's store.
And I think the reason
social was so natural to me
was all the things I learned
between distribution,
under-priced, you just
basically talked about
under-priced attention.
You would buy more strategically
around places that people would look.
You took advantage of the remnant cost.
I did the same exact
stuff on print and outdoor
and direct, you couldn't really do it
the same way on direct mail,
but the other thing I
learned during that year
cause I was doing so much of it,
was the creative was the variable.
Even though I was buying the
full page New York Times ad
in the dining section
at a really good price
cause I knew when to buy it and how,
my ad mattered to how
many people I would get
and I think that that is a big...
A lot of people watching
right now are like,
"But social's not working for me."
And I'm like, "The
creative is the variable."
- And the creative also must
have the key ingredient,
and I'm sure you'd agree with me.
It has to be authentic.
People see through the bullshit now,
you know, if your story's not authentic,
if you don't connect
with them on some basis.
I've even gotten rid of
makeup in most of my postings
cause I find that people respond better
to me looking ugly than
to me all dolled up.
(Gary chuckles)
(hands clap)
Authentic is key
and I don't think that's gonna
change either, of course.
- I agree with you.
You got one parting shot?
We got a minute, I know
these are going quick.
- Okay, so one more thing?
- Please.
- You need to be an entrepreneur
that thrives on change.
I mean, if you don't welcome
change and look for it,
seek it out like a missile like,
"What's next? What's next?"
Like a kid with a curiosity box, right?
You're not gonna be ready
for the changes out there.
I mean, change for me, and I don't think
I'm imagining this happening
probably twice the rate
it would four years ago,
and if your not aware
that today is the single best opportunity
you're ever gonna see
again for the next 10 years
of taking over your
competitors market place.
His beat, cause you can outperform him,
out-create him, outdo
whatever you have to do
to get rid of that guy.
This is the time to do it.
The best time to move ahead
is always in the worst times.
Any smart entrepreneur will tell you
they moved ahead in the worst times
because the big guys
are asleep at the wheel-
- They get tight, they get tight.
- You got it.
- Most people go on defense.
- It's the time to wake up.
- Barbara, it's great to see you.
- Okay, my pleasure.
- Thank you so much for
this 10 minutes, really.
- Thank you very much.
- YouTube watcher, what's up, it's Gary V.
First of all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also want to ask you, please subscribe
because my commitment and
exploration of YouTube
is about to explode.
Stories, polls, more
content, more engagement,
more surprise and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it
and I hope I see you soon.